twisted and burned these derailed train
cars have cast a dark and dangerous
Shadow over this East Ohio Town being
this close to the train derailment I
don't trust it on February 3rd cars
carrying toxic chemicals jumped the
tracks sending a fireball into the air
The Spill has been linked to the deaths
of thousands of animals and health
concerns continue to grow I gotta move
because I'm not safe being here there is
no way we are safe being here the U.S
Environmental Protection Agency says the
air and the water are safe evacuation
orders have been lifted but questions
remain we're going to get to the bottom
of this the White House has not declared
this a disaster because it doesn't meet
the legal requirements meaning FEMA the
agency tasked with disaster relief in
the U.S will only supplement a
multi-agency response we're going to
preemptively file a document with FEMA
to preserve our rights in case we need
their assistance in the future
still FEMA's presence could undercut
comments that East Palestine is safe to
return to we're looking solely at what
would save lives Railways have lobbied
against rules to make trains safer the
trains operator Norfolk Southern
admitted to shareholders in January it's
seen an increase in accidents over the
last four years profits may have
superseded safety recommend stations
many of which are have been on our most
wanted list for decades uh should be
implemented the investigation will
likely look into Legislation during the
Trump Administration laws requiring High
Hazard trains to have electronic breaks
or multiple Crews were rolled back
there's over 4
000 somebody needs helps there will be
lawsuits and Congressional hearings
which could prevent a future incident
but might not heal the wounds of the
past
Global News